وحدات قتاليه غير نظاميه سند روسيا في
حربها في اوكرانيا وذاك لم يعد امرا مخفيا
بل معلنا منذ بدايه الحرب شكلت راس الحربه
في عمليه قتاليه متقدمه وباتت الحاجه
اليها ملحه العمليه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
كما تحب موسكو تسميتها تاخذها اساسا من
خلال جيشها حيث امر الرئيس الروسي في
اغسطس من العام الماضي بزياده عدد القوات
بمقدار 137 الفا لكن الاضواء سلطت اساسا
على بقياده
التي ادرت الهجوم الطويله على مدينه
الاوكرانيه وانتهت مهمتها باخضاع شبه كلي
للمدينه في العشرين من مايوير الماضي
واستعادت كتائب اخرى حليفه للجيش الروسي
بعض الاضواء وتعلق الامر بما يسمى قوات
احمد او مفارز اخماد التي اعلن الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف تشكيلها في حزيران
يونيو العام الماضي واعطاها اسم والده
احمد قديروف
اللافت هو ان المساجين اضحى ورقما في
حسابه الكل حيث كشف مؤسس فاغنر تجنيد نحو
50 الف سجين للقتال معهم وان حوالي 20%
منهم قتلوا في المعارك في اوكرانيا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وفي مسعا واضح لاخضع كل
القوات غير نظاميه ومن تسميهم وحدت
المتطوعين لتعليماتها وخططها وقعت عقدا مع
قوه احمد يقضي بخضوعها لاوامر وزير الدفاع
لتبدو القوه اكثر انسجاما مع المؤسسه
العسكريه في موسكو اضحت بذلك وزاره الدفاع
والقوات الروسيه الوسيطه الذي يحدد ويوجه
باقي القوات غير النظاميه واولها قوه احمد
وقيامها عشره الاف مقاتل مقسمين الى اربع
كتائب عسكريه وفي اظهار مباشر للتحدي رفض
مؤسس فاجنر توقيع عقد ممثل وخاض في الشهور
الاخيره سجلات كثيره مع القياده العسكريه
الروسيه واتهمها بالاخفاق في تقديم الدعم
الكافي
لقوته في اوكرانيا وفيما يبدو مواجهه غير
مباشره ووسيله للتاكيد السيطره
اعطى مجلس النواب الموافقه الاوليه على
تشريع سيسمح لوزاره الدفاع بتوقيع عقود مع
مجرمين مشتبهم او مدانين للقتال في
اوكرانيا الرئيس الروسي قال ان العقود
ضروريه للسماح لجميع المشاركين في الحمله
الروسيه في اوكرانيا بتلقي مستحقاتهم من
مدفوعات الدعم الاجتماعي